[Music]
there are a few moments in the life of
an institution that are historic this is
one of those very rare moments the
living Village is an expression of a
phenomenon that has been studied by
generations of psychologists and other
social scientists as well as by Scholars
of divinity and religion and that is
hope it is historic for Yale Divinity
School not only because it will alter
the physical structure of the school but
it will set an agenda for the
educational program of the school that
will train students as Apostles of the
environment I've waited a long time to
say this line I want to reverse the
lyrics of Joanie Mitchell's song they
tore down Paradise to put up a parking
lot it is time to tear up a parking lot
to put up
[Applause]
Paradise